well terrorists are trying to infiltrate
our borders that is the warning based on
new data from the Homeland Security
Secretary Nielsen who spoke exclusively
to chief intelligence correspondent
catherine herridge about the challenges
were still facing after 9/11 people
think of border security in very
different ways but to me it's very
simple border security is national
security homeland security secretary
Kirsten Nielsen says the wall is part of
a broader counterterrorism strategy we
see 15 terrorists either planning to
travel or actually traveling to the
United States each day known as
suspected terrorists so that means
they're coming through our legal land
port and an air but they could be coming
across that border in New York City for
a series of closed-door threat briefings
Nielsen spoke exclusively with Fox News
at Ground Zero not far from the 2017
attack that killed eight on the Westside
Highway
we're just a few blocks from where that
Isis inspired terrorists mowed down
those pedestrians here in New York using
the Internet the terrorist organizations
are inspiring followers to just pick a
weapon bring your own weapon and use a
car use a knife use something you can
easily pick up and go commit chaos and
murder with the Supreme Court now
weighing the third version of the travel
ban affecting five mostly Muslim
countries Nielsen said the
administration remains committed to
knowing who is entering the u.s. and
whether their home nation is high risk
we owe it to our citizens to know who's
traveling here and if they intend to do
us harm in her first four months on the
job politics seems at play with every
homeland security issue from
congressional funding for the border
wall they all say to me we're in favor
of border security and yet when we try
to work with them on legislation it
falls apart to the recent deployment of
National Guard troops didn't know why I
was controversial we've done this price
before too much success is that a
measure of the politics then I think so
Nielsen pushes back against critics who
say she got the top job because she
worked for John Kelly now White House
chief of staff and the administration's
first DHS chief I've worked at the
crossroads of policy and operations I
kind of bring all that experience
together because Homeland Security is a
team sport and I've played almost every
every player every team almost every
homeland security secretary makes the
pilgrimage to engine 10 ladder 10 near
the base of the Twin Towers it's moving
you know it's kind of reaffirmation of
why we do this the importance of the
mission of the importance of recognizing
the sacrifice of all of our first
responders who truly on a good day put
their lives in danger to protect their
fellow citizens at Ground Zero Catherine
Herridge Fox News